le premier ministre boris johnson
démission de son poste de chef
conservateur oui il ya eu toute une
cascade de deux ministres de membres de
son gouvernement qui est démissionner il
se serait même entretenu avec la reine
ce matin pour l'informer de sa décision
d'autres collaborateurs à londres eric
albert est toujours là pour suivre les
développements on s'était bien dit hier
que saleh se bousculer les événements et
effectivement il ya quelques heures à
peine on n'était même pas sûr qu'il
allait démissionner même si sa
démissionner le du côté des ministres
aux cinq minutes ou à peu près
quel quel chaos absolu et complet autour
de boris johnson ces derniers jours de
fête ça fait trois ans et un peu
chaotique autour de lui c'est quand même
sa spécialité finalement il a annoncé
qu'il allait démissionner on en a aidé à
50 des missions autour de lui un ce
matin cinquante deux ministres le
secrétaire d'état sous secrétaire d'état
est en fait on en arriver au moment où
bouillonnent n'arrivait pas à trouver
des gens pour remplacer les ministres
qu'ils démissionnaient il n'avait plus
d'équipé il n'est plus le gouvernement
qui fonctionnait il a fini par
apparemment reconnaître que
effectivement été incapable de continuer
et il annonce qu'il a fait a annoncé
qu'il allait démissionner sauf que sauf
qu'il y encore quelques questions qu'il
reste notamment qu est-ce qui va
annoncer ce qui démissionne de son poste
de premier ministre tout de suite ou
est-ce que c'est seulement de la
direction du parti conservateur et
s'accroche à son poste de premier
ministre jusqu'à qu' il ya un successeur
à la tête du parti conservateur c'est ce
qui s'est passé avec theresa may la
dernière fois ou alors est ce qu'il
reste encore un peu plus longtemps c'est
pas clair on sait pas exactement ce
qu'il va annoncer on attend sa
déclaration dans deux heures à peu près
il y avait des rumeurs comme quoi ils
essaient de nous mais encore de nouveau
des ministres ce matin il reste encore
un certain nombre de questions donc oui
il va démissionner démissionné de quoi
et à quel moment est-ce qu'il va partir
exactement c'est pas tout à fait certain
il faut faire juste un pas en arrière
pour comprendre qu on ne lui reproche
pas qu'ils se soient produits par
exemple le parti guettant dit bah oui ok
peut-être qu'on peut débattre de sa bon
puncheur bon peut-être mais c'est si le
fait surtout que il pendant longtemps il
ment à ses propres ministres qui volent
des rendre à la radio à la télé tous les
matins du renom dont le premier distance
avait potes et c est là que tout le lien
de bris de confiance sur vienne
c'est exactement ça la connexion s'est
un peu déconnecté quelques instants je
suis pas sur leurs compétences
complètement compris la question mais
j'ai essayé d'y répondre les ministres
ne en veulent pas à boris johnson pour
le président ou pour la façon dont il a
géré la pandémie ou pour la question de
la guerre en ukraine ce qui a vraiment
fini par avoir c'est en fait la fin de
la confiance entre les ministres
eux-mêmes et bo jackson pourquoi parce
que rappelez-vous depuis six mois
maintenant il n'ya pas un ticket de
cette histoire finalement assez assez
anecdotique de petit pot de départ ou de
fête qui a eu un dernier tweet pendant
les confinements ouest est il légal mais
ce qui a vraiment agacé des ministres
s'est pas tellement que oui a sans doute
eu des choses qui ne devait pas avoir
lieu mais que bon il en a menti et il a
envoyé les différents mini ces
différents députés devant les médias
pour leur dire nombreuses autos n'était
absolument pas au courant il n'était
d'ailleurs pas présent à ces fêtes et
aucune règle anne a été violée et puis
devant les évidences il a fallu
reconnaître que en fait johnson était
présent à ces fêtes et que en fait les
règles n'avaient pas été respectés
d'ailleurs voir dobson a reçu une amende
de la police et premier premier ministre
à recevoir officiellement une amende
alors qu'il est en poste et donc les
ministres les députés les supporters qui
étaient venus devant les médias pour le
défend se sont sentis trahis et didier
il dit yo en disant mais on a dit des
choses qui étaient de fait fausse et
encore une fois on s'est fait avoir
parce que prochain bon il nous a menti
de nouveau un mini scandale de ce genre
a eu lieu la semaine dernière et de
nouveaux bons hilton a commencé par
mentir et de nouveau les ministres sont
arrivés devant les médias en disant des
choses fausses malgré eux ils ont eu
marre ils ont eu trois ans ça suffit
maintenant on arrête ce premier ministre
n'est pas capable de ne pas mentir
pendant deux jours de suite il n'est pas
capable de maîtriser sa communication et
on passe en permanence pour des idiots
maintenant il faut partir bon dit deux
mots rapidement comment va choisir le
chef à partir de maintenant s'il dit il
dit le jeu je quitte le poste de premier
ministre je quitte le chef de la
position de chef de parti
le caucus le conseil des ministres a
beaucoup à voir d'abord dans le le
triage des candidats non alors la façon
dont ça se passe la saison s'est passé
avec theresa may la dernière fois c'est
maintenant le parti conservateur qui va
désigner un nouveau leader les députés
les 3 159 députés conservateurs vont
nommer entre deux candidats dont qu'il a
il ya au moins une demi-douzaine de
candidats déclarés les marathons
d'autres ils vont sélectionner deux et
ensuite ces deux là vont passer devant
le les membres des partis conservateur
et c'est les membres du parti
conservateur qui vont voter ça va
prendre six semaines deux mois environ
d'ici la fin de l'été environ on devrait
avoir un successeur à la tête du parti
conservateur on va très bien continuer à
prendre du jus d'orange et nourrissez
vous bien de vitamines parce que vous
allez être occupés merci eric avoir
terminé merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici r d
[Musique]